is seneca martin green
wait y'all
i don't i don't know what this is
wait got it i see it now
hey there i'm siniqua martin green and
today i will be doing the
wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
who is cynical martin green
i am me and that's who i am i look
forward to becoming more me
as i get older who is the nipple martin
green
parents well that is charles and vera
martin those are my parents they live in
alabama
who is the neuqua martin greene oh mary
too
yes honey well that is a hug of a man
love of my life
ken rick green who is also an actor who
is sneaking morton green
in new girl well i play ronda
in new girl and rhonda is crazy the
craziest prankster you've ever known
and a lot of people want to fight rhonda
and that was a whole lot of fun to do
how tall is suniq martin green i am five
four and a half and i'm going to hold on
to that half
as long as i possibly can how to
pronounce
senegal martin greene it is siniqua i've
heard sequoia seneca sakina
i have heard i get shaniqua more often
than anything
people will even read it on paper and
say shaniqua
as if it's a silent age how old is the
neuqua martin green i am happily
35. love getting older
was cynical martin green here we go
we're going into the past
what's the neuqua martin green pregnant
on
walking dead yes i was i was actually
just pregnant again
i have a brand new little baby but yes i
was pregnant with my
my beautiful perfect son during season
five
of walking dead i was pregnant the
entire season when we wrapped i was
about eight months
the good thing is that you know zombie
apocalyptic wear
had a lot of layers and i had my big m5
so i could hide behind that and i was
all belly which helped
as well everybody cared for me uh
so much lovely show family they took
good care
was siniqua martin greene
in gossip girl i was
one episode don't remember what my
character's name was though
but it was fun can't sneak one green
let's find out if i can okay
can sneak martin green sing no i cannot
sing
i wish that i could i really appreciate
that gift
i do sing in the shower and in the car
like most people do
cancer neuqua martin green accents
everybody has an accent right depending
on
where you're from in the world i do have
a southern accent
i cover it up most of the time but it's
there and it does peek out a lot
and it comes out a lot more the older i
get
too i can do a little bit of new york
you know what i'm saying like because i
used to live there
i can do that i can do british
pretty well and i and i like it it's a
lot of fun for me to do
i did it professionally one time in an
off-broadway show
in new york at the vineyard theatre
which is near union square
and it kind of gets on my husband's
nerves from time to time
cancer neuqua martin green act can i
y'all tell me
can i act because i hope so
it'd be awkward if i couldn't right okay
here we go we moved on to the does
i'm going to peel it backwards and see
if it helps yeah does senegal martin
green have siblings i have
lots of siblings i have
one um whole sister and i have three
uh half sisters but then also another
sister
it's a lot of sisters and it's all um
even though they're half
it's all real and i love them does sin
equal martin green have a son
i do i have a gorgeous perfect full of
joy
son named kenrick green
ii does siniqua martin green
no martial arts thank you for this
question
i appreciate you thank you i don't know
martial arts but i did study stage
combat
in college i was able to get certified
in all eight weapons that the society of
american fight directors
offers which was a lot of fun okay what
senegal martin green okay what
nationality is sneaker martin green
okay so i'm black but there is a lot of
other stuff
in my lineage um i just you know did my
dna
did my dna what i had my dna tested okay
and it did turn up that i'm mostly
nigerian um there's some cameroon
in there there's uh mali but then
there's also
english scottish there's a little bit of
a spain
a tiny bit of france and i
do also believe that there's a lot of
native in my family too my mother has
not had her dna tested yet so once her
blood is in the mix or well really once
her dna is in the mix
i'll see because um that's where the
native comes from so
it's from her side
what sign is sunique martin green i am
an aries
i am the first day of aries my birthday
is march 21st
uh 3 2 1 here i come is what i like to
say
so because i'm the first day of aries i
guess i'm technically a pisces aries
cusp
what language does sunipo martin green
um no languages what languages does the
nick martin green
only english which is unfortunate um
i know a little bit of asl
i can i can go through the alphabet
really really quickly
i am in the process of learning french
right now actually my husband and i
and i would love to learn spanish as
well
and see there i go because speak was
right there i'm sitting here laughing at
this when there was this
that's on me my bad but yeah i hope i
can uh speak english better one day
also
is sunique martin green related to
oh i already know angela bassett
i already knew that okay i have heard
for so much of my life that i look
just like angela bassett that i look
like a younger
version of her i love her
i looked uh up to her a lot when i was
really little
i would love to look like her i think
she's beautiful i think she's
she's a queen i am not related to her
though but maybe one day i'll play her
daughter how about that
is the nipple martin green leaving
discovery
i mean one day one day i guess we'll all
leave discovery
won't we because one day the show will
be done but
i don't anticipate leaving the show
before it's done
is siniqua martin green
wait y'all
i don't i don't know what this is
wait got it i see it now
[Laughter]
see this is the problem when you peel
off the letters you don't see what it is
it's asian
i am not asian that would be cool if i
was
but i am not i have also heard that uh
my whole life uh funny story i was
walking
um i was walking outside
in new york city years ago on halloween
and i was walking with my friends and
somebody yelled across the street
gots to be black and asian
oh my goodness y'all i'm really bad at
peeling these off
clearly is the neuqua martin green in
space jam
yes i am i play lebron's wife um
we're excited about that it was a lot of
fun and i look forward to it uh coming
out
oh my goodness this is the last board
it's an equal martin green instagram so
i do have an instagram
um i think my handle is the real
sennequa yeah
it is i don't post a lot uh
yeah i should probably post more
but i don't yeah and then here we go
snickering green twitter so i have a
twitter too
i think it's siniqua mg this is
craziness that i don't know
that goes to show you how often i am not
on these platforms
but yes i do have a twitter that i also
do not post enough
on cinema green autograph that's the
thing
i guess that exists sometimes
it's nick martin green sasha williams
yeah that's who i played on the walking
dead
it's a morning green short hair
yes so
this was kind of a thing i um cut my
hair recently
this is actually the shortest my hair
has been in a really long time
but my hair was becoming such a thing it
was um
very long and took a lot to take care of
i found myself at a period in my life
where
i could not make sense of how much time
it was taking i wanted to spend that
time doing
other things more important things so i
cut it all off
and it was the best thing ever
measurements what are you doing
you no
i don't know what they are right now
because i am
uh freshly postpartum so they are very
different than they were before i was
pregnant
which is a beautiful thing
siniqua martin green piers morgan
y'all getting into it huh okay i was on
with him
and we got into a little bit of a debate
it went well
i was glad that it happened i felt like
it was
necessary thank you guys for asking all
these questions
thank you for even asking questions at
all i appreciate you
and i hope you have a good one
[Applause]
i hope you have a good one much love to
you
i can't be trusted throwing these boards